today on stick to football we have our
cash or trash on NFL rumors your draft
on draft questions all the latest draft
news and a sit-down interview between
myself and Jacob Eason which you can
watch on our YouTube playlist bleach
reports YouTube channel Matt Melo and
Connor you can also watch the entire
show there if you just really miss
seeing people because what else are you
doing I know I do man I miss being
around other humans I love you guys I
miss being around other human beings I
was actually thinking about this on my
drive into the office like I come into
the office it's not really like an
office though it's it's just me and you
here yeah so I don't give people the
wrong idea this guy still go to it is
literally me and Matt that's it
but until roughly three 3345 today can't
talk to another person at all I don't
know if I had actually said words out
loud other than singing while trying to
watch players
yeah it's bizarre and another thing I
was thinking of usually I mean there's a
point in the season where I see you guys
almost every other week easily but since
we're all gonna be doing the draft and
yes there will be a PR giraffe show
don't worry about that it'll feel just
as good as all the other ones but I
won't see you guys till TVD it might be
over half a year
wait guys which is crazy on our timeline
it is I got a man well I remember when I
hadn't seen you for a couple months when
I was like being real strict on working
out dieting and you were like all right
yeah I really distracting from you next
time
get to work why did you 40 pounds on
quarantine what are you gonna do
yeah the corona 15 everybody's nervous
about it so yeah I think I got the 15 in
the first week all I do is all I do is
eat since I'm always home like it's I
don't know I guess it when you're a walk
from the fridge for your entire workday
it's so easy to just eat all day now you
guys understand how I got kind of plump
there for a while I've never worked just
walk from home the thing that's gonna
counter it for me is the fact that I
haven't been drinking alcohol which
sorry man I have so hopefully that
balances out because I take in a lot of
calories through beer even though it's
light beer I take in a lot of
calories through beer same okay let's
actually get to the show what you guys
came here for to of talking about Louis
says he's 100% could play right now
and according to NFL Network that has
been verified now by an independent
doctor so I would like to thank Leigh
Steinberg his age up for listening to
stick to football because do you
remember last week where we went on a
rant about this of like - I can say he's
healthy only once until a third party
says it I'm going to be a little bit
skeptical well a third party has now
said it guys they went he went through a
full medical check all 32 team doctors
were able to get the results and also
have input in what was being checked on
to a by this unbiased medical
professional and so now guys it sounds
like we had thought maybe tool was a
draft and stash player for 2020 that
might not actually be the case from a
medical standpoint yeah and if your team
like the Dolphins or you know some of
these other teams I think it's a good
sign because you have a quarterback
that's already kind of in place there
that you know can play and Fitzpatrick
but I'm still hesitant to buy in to the
to of thing I know that people keep
saying it and I believe it I want to
believe it but I'm still skeptical of
even a third party guy I sold a car once
on Craigslist and we took it to a
mechanic a third party mechanic it was
supposed to check over the car I knew it
was a piece of [ __ ] but guess what he
took about five minutes checked it over
they were like will you check the
transmission he crawled under the car
looked at something I heard a knocking
sound came back was like yep it's all
good it's like really that's we're gonna
go with that it's all good so third
parties not always that reliable
especially when you're selling a car on
Craigslist good and I still think yeah I
still think the biggest thing for me
guys is not to a getting healthy is to a
staying healthy so I'm happy I'm happy
that he looks great he looks nimble he
looks healthy he's moving around it
sounds like if there's ever a training
camp starting on time or if it's late
he'll be you know hopefully a full
participant all that stuff is great the
biggest thing about to a tongue of Eylau
uh and the reason he's not my number one
quarterback in this class is because I
just have concerns about him
reactivating whether it's ankle hip or
just a new injury so for tua this is
great news and we've said it on the show
for a very long time he's
going to be top five pick probably top
three pick but just hopefully you know
people keep sight of the most important
thing and that's staying healthy long
term so I didn't put this on the rundown
I teased it a little bit to Connor
before the show but I wanted to drop
some news right now on the show and this
is my scouting notebook that comes out
every Friday if you listen to this
Friday morning it happened to be our app
and read it I have talked to multiple
teams this week guys one has to as QB
for another has to it as QB three and
it's not because injury there are there
Scouts there GM's there coaches that
believe he's basically the product of a
system at Alabama that had four first
rounders at receiver two first rounders
at offensive tackle now I don't agree
with this and I've pushed back on it
he's my number two quarterback he's a
top 10 player for me but I wanted to I
wanted to get your guys take on the idea
out there that too is maybe not as good
as the three of us and a lot of people
in the media belief I think when you're
evaluating any position but specifically
the quarterback position it's hard not
to look at what players have around him
you look at Joe burrow Joe burrow had
every bit of talent around him that to
Otunga Loyola did but we're not knocking
him on oh man look at what Justin
Jefferson and Jamar chased it we're
talking about Jamar chase already is one
of the best receiver prospects we've
seen he's got two years of tape one
really good year so I think it's unfair
to say well look at what - it did I went
back and watched some of his tape today
actually I think he does do a really
good job of throwing his receivers open
now they do a great job also of making
plays but when I'm making a projection
of what his two were going to do he
throws with anticipation he throws with
accuracy if he can add arm strength and
he can stay healthy I think he's an
elite level prospect in this draft
probably even higher than a guy like Joe
burrow I think the arm strength is a
real concern for a lot of teams but when
you see that accuracy the little bit of
mobility that he has I mean it's a Drew
Brees what he can be is Drew Brees in
the NFL I'm with you there Melo I look
at - and he's a lock as quarterback -
even with the health risk I think he is
miles ahead of Justin Herbert a Jordan
love he really really is and when you
look at those other two guys a lot of
teams are gonna fall in love with them
it's the same thing we saw when Josh
Allen was a prospect you know a big
big mobile quarterback that is very raw
and the accuracy comes and goes and the
turnovers are a problem I think there's
a lot of similar questions with not just
Jordan love but specifically Justin
Herbert but there are evaluators that
they take into you know take into
account upside overall and I look at to
and see a high level starter if he's
healthy he just might not have the look
some people are looking for cuz he's not
six five maybe he doesn't run like some
of those guys maybe he doesn't throw the
ball seventy yards off his back foot in
an indoor workout but the things that
matter in an NFL game Toa does very very
well throwing accurately to all three
levels of the field the feel in the
pocket the leadership and that's why I'm
still a believer but Matt - back to your
report I'm not terribly surprised yeah
especially when like Melo said arm
strength is it major concern for a lot
of people and that's Justin Herbert big
arm Jordan love big arm you're gonna
hear Jacob Eason talking about his arm
strength in our interviewed segment
three there are quarterbacks in this
class that definitely have a bigger arm
than two all right we're gonna talk a
little bit more about mr. tua in the
cash or trash segment but how about this
guy's the market for Jadeveon Clowney is
starting to heat up and the two teams
that have been linked to him not the
Seattle Seahawks Connors New York Jets
which that is a gigantic need for them
they definitely have the money to pay
for a decade but also the Tennessee
Titans who they picked up Big B's name
for agency they have Harold Landry who
they drafted a couple years ago in the
second round
clowny on the Titans should terrify fans
of the AFC yeah I think so too
yeah I as a fan in the AFC that that is
scary and looking at the Titan
specifically I think edge rush are still
in need Landry is still young and kind
of unproven and you just don't know what
you have opposite of him
I mean you could get 20 sacks you could
get two so I think bringing in an edge
rusher or something that Vrabel in this
front office is going to try to do if
not via the draft and yeah take a look
at a guy like cloudy and free agency see
what he wants I think that his market is
heating up but I think those dollar
signs are dropping that's exactly what
it feels like but if you're cloudy and
you're sitting there and you're like I
might take a one-year seventeen million
dollar deal and if that deal is not
coming from Seattle Tennessee would be
the
I would go because of the coaching
although I will say with the New York
Jets Greg Williams is another guy that
might let him pin his ears back and go
and have a super productive year so
Vrabel
Greg Williams those are other options
for clowny that do make a lot of sense
if he's looking to hey I had three and a
half sacks last year the long-term deals
are not on the table for me I have to
take a prove-it deal which let's be real
guys a one-year seventeen million dollar
deal it's still a very very good
contract for a player that when healthy
is very very productive so I wouldn't be
surprised to see him land in Tennessee
if he has to go that route if I'm if I'm
him I go to the Titans not only they're
a better team no student comes out yeah
that's extra ten percent your pocket
that's 1.7 million dollars on a one-year
seventeen million dollar deal that's a
no-brainer for me and then the fit would
Mike Vrabel with clownin I thought his
game against the Niners was that week
seventeen was one of the best games I
saw an edge player have all season but
he just was never on the field it's
funny a guy who coming out of college
was like what a freak show edge rusher
really he was the first of those like
generational guys that we now have every
year but he was the first one there's
obviously the Hat the hit against
Michigan that everybody remembers but
isn't that we're that clowny
I think clowny is actually a little bit
of a disappointment as a first-round
pick or as the number one overall pick
he has not lived up to that status as a
number one pick I mean even during his
you know first couple years with Texans
as I got yeah nine sacks a second year
nine and a half that's really it that's
all we've seen from him even you know
last year three sacks
yeah that's it's not good production
from guy that everybody was saying after
that hit against Michigan and the bowl
game like this is the best edge rusher
we've ever seen yeah I mean living up to
number one overall expectations I do not
think so otherwise he would have gotten
a long-term deal to keep him through his
prime whether it was in with the Texans
or now with Seattle and those deals have
not been on the table and then you look
at what someone like Miles Garrett is a
good example right and I know it's
frustrating because miles Garrett was
suspended for the end of the season last
year but when Miles Garrett's been on
the field there's never a time where you
sit there and go that guy was a number
one overall pick every single week you
look at what Myles does and Heat
the game so for cloudy it's been a good
player it's been a good run defender the
pressures are there the sack numbers are
not but in terms of living up to
expectations I don't think he has how I
played one full season as well was it
that year he had nine and a half yep
yeah it's been a while it's been a
minute for that speaking of having been
a minute for an edge rusher I I don't
know if you guys saw this all Ben Smith
signed with the Dallas Cowboys on
Thursday morning Alden Smith hasn't
played since 2015 now this is contingent
upon him being reinstated by the NFL
when I retire Ivan Alden Smith story to
tell it's real good it's gonna be the
new Charles Haley it's gonna be yeah
it's good it's not never we're available
to travel again you can ask Matt about
the all good it heard it so I don't know
if it's even on the table for that right
now yeah I don't know if it is but I
mean he has it for years thinks guy
hasn't been in the NFL they're giving
him a one-year four million dollar deal
with a two million base two million in
sack incentives you know I'm happy for
Alden Smith I hope he's clean and sober
and ready to go
but if your deck Prescott how pissed off
for you right now that everyone in the
world is getting a deal from the Dallas
Cowboys except for you like I would be
upset and I know maybe like that's not
Dax personality maybe there's no ego
there but everyone is getting taken care
of except for you at this point I I
think the attack is probably aware that
he is a top priority but they're also
still trying to build the team around
him it does kind of feel like maybe the
Cowboys are gonna try to play him on
this franchise tag though like I haven't
heard talks about dak in a contract for
a while now but you're right everybody
else seems to be getting a deal you go
and find an edge rusher that hasn't
played football in four years and snatch
him up but you can't get a deal done
with your franchise quarterback it's a
little bit sketchy it's pretty crazy I
mean it feels like they're they're
throwing a dart to replace some of
Robert Quinn's production who got paid a
lot more than anyone expected from
Chicago yeah now with Aldon Smith I mean
he hasn't been a double-digit
double-digit sack player since 2012 and
then his career started to kind of trend
downwards after that he is 30 years old
already and we'll see what he has
hopefully it's a it's a really good
comeback story and it's not shocking
when Dallas takes these kind of Flyers
that no one else right I mean this is a
team that brought in Greg Hardy so yeah
I had rusher out of Nebraska that had a
Randy Gregory Randy
not surprised they like an edge rusher
with a little bit of a troubled past at
least you meant exactly yeah red flags
all about it
alright Derrick Henry the running back
not the addressee signs his franchise
tender guys which very very smaller by
Derrick Henry to just go ahead and sign
that thing don't Melvin Gordon this
thing sign that franchise tender get
your money and this ensures that he will
be playing for the Tennessee Titans this
year I have heard from some sources with
the team they're trying to work on an
extension it would not necessarily be
long-term when we think of like
quarterbacks our offensive tackles but
they're trying to get something done
that would give him some security for
the next two to three years but Derrick
Henry and Joe Tunney now two players
have signed that franchise tender and
what I believe in the right in chef
brain is sure if that's right yeah
offensive tackle our offensive guards
running backs get your money when you
can yeah and I think this is a good move
by Henry I think that every running back
should thank Melvin Gordon because last
year he tried this and it didn't work
out and we saw what happened he goes and
he plays on a two-year deal now with the
Broncos I think you have to sign your
franchise tag it's not a great system
but I think that's what you have to do
with the running back position
especially going into year five you've
had one dominant season last year rushed
for 1,500 yards
I think the franchise tag is almost
going to be a prove-it deal for him as
is this something that you can sustain
is it's something we can do again is it
something we can build around if it is
then the next contract yeah we'll pay
you probably not a lot not getting Zeke
Elliott money but I think they'll take
care of him I think Mike Vrabel is a
good guy when it comes to contract
negotiations I'm sure that he's very
honest and upfront with Henry and
Tannehill and what's going on with
everybody in that front office are you
guys surprised the franchise tag still
exists in the new CBA agreement yes it's
a very shy I'm surprised that exists for
running backs like that's a really good
point actually if I were on a team yeah
I'm a general manager I'm using that
franchise tag on running backs if
they're good every time if I were
running back in the NFL I would have
done everything possible to make it
abolished for my position because you're
just completely devalued and now you
know we're not we're seeing guys after
three or four years you're just done
you're you're not getting you know that
you're not getting the security because
a franchise tag will make you play under
it for two years and then
and we'll go to someone else damaged
goods that's why running backs kind of
have some value in the first round to
get your five years with them give them
to franchise tags cut him loose that's
what everybody expected the Cowboys to
do I was very short I would I didn't but
I think that you can do that with with
running backs and it is pretty shitty to
just say well we know what you're worth
but you really can't sign anywhere else
I think at a minimum they should have
found a way to make it more difficult
for teams to use it you know whether
it's you can use it once in a row not
two to three times or you pay the
average of the top two salaries not top
five I do think it's become too much of
a layup decision and it's consistently
hurt the top players at the free agent
market also another thing guys that um
you know I know the NFL the owners want
the tag I totally understand it it would
be more entertaining going into free
agency without the franchise oh the top
ten players every single year off the
get-go and then you're sitting there
going wow there's maybe two tier 1
players and then a million tier two and
three and four players in free agency
because all these guys got franchise
tagged and it was all the waste of time
oh yeah like this year if everyone who
is a free agent actually became a free
agent it like if Yannick ikkaku who's
tweeting on Thursday night who needs
pass rushers that dude were a free agent
come like the NBA does it I mean where
you have you dominate a whole month or a
summer because of free agency how
baseball does III think that then if L
can't do the same thing in it
we're probably not gonna see the
franchise tag go away anytime soon but
it would be very exciting and I think
the players would be on board with it
and it's something they should probably
bring up next time they can negotiate
this in 2030 when they can negotiate it
the last thing before we get to cash or
trash a lot of teams are scrambling
trying to figure out where they will
hold their drafts from the Chiefs are
doing it in Andy Reid's basement the
Saints are doing it in a brewery owned
by the team by Tom Benson there's taking
over a brewery which I've never wanted
to be in a team's draft room more than
the Saints at a brewery and I hope that
not to offend any Saints fans wouldn't
it be hilarious if they like messed up
if the time ran out on the Saints and
everybody's like
[ __ ] they must be throwing them back
pretty hard in the brewery Sean Payton's
getting toasty with Mickey Loomis yeah
it's it's very cool idea I'm curious to
see more of these trickle in now over
the next couple of weeks and it feels
like after that latest NFL memo that was
not exactly quite clear teams could be
doing it from their bedrooms
the GM's bedroom teams could be maybe
trying to get back into their facilities
or drinking beers who knows right jeez
the NFL man they're they're hell-bent on
this happening and who knows where we'll
be happening from we will be right here
covering it take a break we come back
cash or trash then Jacob Eason it is
game time we're gonna play a little cash
or trash on some rumors that I've been
hearing over the last week and I always
like to just specify here it doesn't
mean I believe the rumor which is why we
played this game but these are things
that actually are being said around NFL
front office right now let's go right
here first guys the New York Giants a
pick number four overall I've heard
they're zeroing in on Isaiah Simmons Mel
O'Connor cash or trash I'm going cash on
this one it seems like a good Dave
gentlemen pick I don't like it and I
know Giants fans gonna be pissed at me I
don't care I don't like him in a Dave
gentlemen defense and a Dave gentlemen
built team I want to see him be used in
a more versatile way I'm afraid that if
the Giants take him they're gonna say
all right play middle linebacker I don't
I know they have a new head coach I know
they have a new defensive coordinator
those guys both came from the Patriots
that run a lot of three four three
fronts I don't like Isaiah Simmons there
but I do think that's going to be the
pick I mean we always see Leakes come
out of New York with the Giants I think
this is just another case of they tip
their hat somebody found out who they're
taking and they leaked that information
yeah
gentlemen's picks get leaked you know
pretty much every year and it's usually
around this time so people sit there and
go is this a smoke screen or is this not
and there's been times where I believe
there was a smoke screen those days are
done this is cash to me guys I think
when you look at the Giants they did
invest a lot of money at linebacker in
free agency but there's still room for
someone like Simmons that can play
safety that can cover in the slot and
that can come down and it's the box as a
linebacker now I'll say this about the
pick
I think the Giants should take the best
tackle available protect Daniel Jones
give him a shot get more run you know
running room for
say qualms Barkley I think the Giants
would be crazy here to not bolster that
tackle position I mean you're gonna go
into the season with Nate's older who
has had back problems for a long time
cam Fleming who has really been a backup
as your tackles the Giants are in prime
position to get a really really good
offensive line piece but I think when
all is said and done Isaiah Simmons
which is exciting for the defense is
gonna be a New York giant one thing I'll
add I have heard like some quiet buzz
that Tristan wharfs is a player they
like I had someone coming me on Twitter
over this and they said no way new right
like if you knew so much about the
Giants why did you have them taking
Dwayne Haskins last year and I didn't I
didn't clap back I thought we would just
address it on the show I was actually
told around this time last year that
they liked Daniel Jones I didn't believe
it I didn't think they were dumb enough
to draft Daniel Jones at 7 overall so I
heard it I just didn't believe it so
that's like the hard thing with these
rumors is sometimes you hear something
and you're like no they're not come on
they went RAF Daniel Jones at 7 so I had
heard it from a really good source just
didn't believe it I think this is cash
as well whether it should be Tristan
wharfs or Jedrek wills or Isaiah Simmons
I think Dave gentlemen with this new
head coach with what they want to do
running like you said Mel whether it's a
Patriots defense or a 30 stack you know
that they're trying to implement here
we've talked about Isaiah Simmons to say
position let's player just let him be a
matchup you got to defend Zach Ertz okay
we got Isiah Simmons you got to take
away you know whatever option whether
it's slot receivers stop the run stop
mobile quarterbacks he can do a little
bit of everything so the value is
definitely there for me
I do think tackle is a bigger need and a
more of a premium position but I got a
lot of Isiah Simmons right second rumor
we talked a little bit about tua in the
opening segment but guys one thing that
I have heard a lot and it's another one
of those you start hearing it and you're
like I don't believe this then you hear
more and more and more and you have to
give it credit is that the Dolphins
don't want to uh I was on the phone
Wednesday with someone who told me that
fans need to start in Miami fans need to
start opening basically opening up to
the possibility that they could draft
Justin Herbert whether in a trade up or
at number five overall but Dolphins fans
like hell-bent the two of their guy and
if they don't get him they're going to
revolt
I'm just here to tell you dolphins fans
there are a lot of people in the NFL who
think your team would draft Justin
Herbert / - oh right now yeah I think
there's a lot of different opinions you
know what we say on this podcast isn't
law it's not fact it's everything's an
opinion here so all of us have to is our
quarterback - I think me and Connor like
him a little bit more than Matt but it
takes one team it takes one team with
the Dolphins saying I actually really
like Justin Herbert more I'm going to go
- sorry Mel so I'm gonna go trash on
this one though because I think this is
the Dolphins trying to sit back at five
and not have to trade up for him I think
there's gonna be a lot of information
leaking out this is ly season I think
that they do like to it but I don't
think they want to trade up for him I
think they want to keep all those picks
that they acquired so I have a similar
thought Melo even though I went cash
with the steak I don't think they like
him enough to move up for him yeah which
is why I think they won't get him I
think they'll sit there five let the
board break to them and they'll take
Justin Herbert and be happy with that I
think the Charger's or someone like them
will be more aggressive moving to three
or four and take tua when all is said
and done now if - is there five
I'm sure yeah I mean you have to take
them he'd be crazy not to but I think
the Dolphins Walton Utley get jumped and
I don't think Chris Greer is a guy
that's gonna panic and say I'm not
giving away my entire draft to go up cuz
teams are gonna ask for a lot of their
assets they have all when you have that
much cash coming to the table teams are
gonna get really really greedy so I'm
gonna go with cashier overall I'm also
gonna cash on this I think there's a
strong possibility that that there are
high ranked people in Miami who aren't
sold on to a it ultimately will come
down to what Steve and Ross the owner
the Dolphins tells them to do because
when you're drafting a quarterback the
owner has to sign off on it so I think
Steven Ross who saw - a play a lot coach
football the last two years may have
something to say with this and I will
just throw this in there we don't have
to discuss it if you guys don't want but
there's also I mean there's considerable
amount of talk to the Dolphins with all
those picks this year and next could
call the Bengals and say you know what
if Joe burrow doesn't want to play there
maybe you should trade back to five and
take Justin Herbert
we'll take Joe burrow he can come play
for the Miami Dolphins yeah I just that
asking price it to be high the Dolphins
have the picks to do it I don't trading
away from that number one pick two
get off of the quarterback that you want
I just don't think that's gonna happen I
think when I look at it I don't think
the Bengal cell no matter what it's so
hard if you're Cincinnati to sit there
and go yeah we we sold the number one
pick so you're not getting Joe borough
but we believe in Justin Herbert and now
we're gonna take all these other players
man right you better be right if you do
that and I just don't think the Bengals
will take that risk especially for a
local kid you know he's from two hours
away that's the thing you know and it's
like so highly respected right third
rumor guys CD lamb why'd you sir from
Oklahoma is the number one wide receiver
for the Las Vegas Raiders and the New
York Jets I'm buying this one big time I
think it's cash I love CD lamb the more
I watch him the closer he gets to a guy
like Jerry Judy I and I think when you
look at these two teams specifically
with the Jets I believe it because I
think they want a guy with that big
catch radius for Sam Donald with the
Raiders I I think they would probably
prefer a guy like rug's who can take the
top off the defense but I bet there are
a lot of teams I 15 teams maybe even the
half CD lamb is their number one
receiver in this class yeah so I hope
you're right Melo because CD lamb is my
favorite wide receiver in this trap but
I'm gonna go trash here I think for the
Raiders it'll be someone like rugs I
think they'll value the speed I think
for the Jets
I think they'll value Judy but you know
just looking at their offense but man I
hope I'm wrong here I really hope CD
lamb is number one wide receiver on both
boards so I'm gonna go cash on this it's
tough because I I could see the Raiders
I've said it before you have to face
Tyree kill twice a year you know how
valuable that is you would want to henry
rugs with jerry judy he's just such a
polished route runner it's hard to
imagine anyone not liking him I think
what's gonna happen it's gonna be four
teams like it is for us these three
receivers are gonna be stacked very very
closely together and you're gonna like
they're so different than three of them
that you could find a use for every
player and it's gonna be different
within your own scheme all right how
about this one I'm anxious to see what
you guys think about this the Arizona
Cardinals reportedly what Derrick brown
at number eight overall not an offensive
tackle which is I think where a lot of
us thought they might go but the
extended DJ Humphries they trade for new
cop khun's could Derrick brown be off
the board at 8 Melo I think they've made
a lot of moves on offhand saying you
looking at kif let's try that Kliff
Kingsbury and what he wants to build I
think a lot of us figure like they're
gonna go off in so they're gonna go
tackle they're gonna go receiver they
address the receiver position they bring
it back guys at tackle I think it is
start time for them to start building
this defense Derrick brown is one of the
best interior lineman in this draft I
think you look at him in Javon Kinlan
then there's a big drop-off after that
so I'm going cash on this one I do think
that they want somebody that can disrupt
from the interior and that's Derrick
brown they desperately need help inside
I know they signed Jordan Phillips but
this was not a hey we get one guy in
free agency and we're good they need two
guys on top of Chandler Jones on the
edge there so I think when you look at
the air with the Cardinals here I'm
buying this this is cash Derek Brown at
8 makes a lot of sense I'll say this you
know we've talked ourselves in interest
and wharfs being the pick there I don't
even know if he's available in that spot
but I also go back to something that
matt has said for God it feels like a
full year now we just don't know how
much cliff values offensive lineman in
that kind of light in terms of top 10
picks you know they were very
comfortable bringing back their own I
could see them going defense on this one
yeah I could as well I'm gonna shun this
one I trust the person who told me
number one and then I really do think
that when you look at their roster
construction Derek Brown would fit and
they're so in love with Chandler Jones
they want to free him up
Derek Browns gonna do that I mean look
what he did at Auburn freeing people up
so I think that would be a very good
pick for them if he's on the board no
guarantee he'll be there a last one guys
there are beloved Dallas Cowboys rumor
is they could go wide receiver in the
first or second round when we talk about
Dallas they're always like edge rusher D
lineman corner they sign Amari Cooper
but a third receiver in this offense I
think it's a pretty big need I do too
and it wouldn't surprise me I'm gonna go
cash here because with the Cowboys I
think they could load up on targets and
I with these receivers they could go 11
12 13 or the
Cowboys could be sitting there what are
they 1617 and we won't have a receiver
off the board yet and if they're sitting
there with their number one receiver on
the board it would not be surprised if
they take them because if all the
receivers are sitting there good chance
that a corner or two has come off the
board then a defensive lineman like
Derrick brown or Javon Kinlaw they're
probably gone as well and then the
Cowboys are sitting there saying well
what are our needs we're gonna take you
guys Avior McKinney he doesn't really
move the needle for me I think he's
gonna be a very good solid player I
don't think he's gonna be spectacular so
if you're matching him up or any safety
in this class with a guy like C D lamb
or Jerry Judy yeah I think the Cowboys
are in a great position to say let's go
take a difference-maker on offense that
can free up Cooper and help this guy at
quarterback dak Prescott
I'm gonna go cashier as well I'm not
thinkin around one I'm thinkin around
two with this pick I think the Cowboys
are in a good spot to get Jalen raker
maybe maybe Brandon Iuka Falls maybe
they like somebody that can be more of
an instant production possession guy and
Michael Pittman who does have speed to
win over the top I think what Dallas
here there's no doubt about that they do
need a third receiver and I think with
that second-round pick it makes a lot of
sense in this class yeah when I when I
heard this at first is like gosh that's
early but then the more you think about
it and look at their roster it's like
actually makes a lot of sense I know
they're like Michael Gallup obviously
they love Amari Cooper but if you can
get a cage a handler at jaylen rhaegar I
I know Melo won't agree with us there's
been some love for Devin Duvernay it's
like a late second round pick so someone
who could play that slot role may be
helping the return game would definitely
be big thing I think with the Cowboys
your Super Bowl window it's shrinking
you're paying a lot of guys a lot of
money your Super Bowl window shrinking
over these next couple years I think you
probably have four years to try to win
with this team that you have before you
have to start replacing a lot of your
key pieces especially on that offensive
line all right let's take a break we
come back you get to hear myself and
Jacob Eason talk about chugging beers
and strong arms all right we got my man
Jacob Eason on today quarterback from
the University of Washington and first
of all I appreciate you doing this
because I know that you're busy right
now how many of these base times zoom
meetings have you done with NFL teams in
the last month
Timur repeated an interview resume at
least making a killing our house it
sucks to say with all this going on but
you know wish I could give a little more
face-to-face and personal time with
these things
but throughout these it's been good how
are you trying to stay in shape when I
mean you're in you're in the state of
Washington where they've you know one of
the first places where they kind of told
people to lock down how are you able to
stay in shape you know and especially
throw like some of these linemen like
they can still lift they can do their
shorter agility you need 75 yards to
throw with at least how are you finding
space and time to do that yes stay down
here watched it pretty far in California
pretty hard but I figured there's a
little bit better weather and and you
know more resources to use the Train
down here so I've been really you know
it's trying to stay low-key and sneaky
about it and really obviously we want to
do social distancing and trying to stay
safe with all this virus stuff going
around but I've been able to get out of
the field with just a couple guys and
really you know obviously wash your
hands and everything going around
through the beating and the workout and
then you know obviously other facility
here and everybody I know they spot
working on with the limited amount of
people and get my work in and kind of
stay under the radar stay healthy and
try to play this this bug going around
have you had teams ask you about it you
know how you know how serious are you
taking it what it what kind of
precautions are you taking or it's
everyone just kind of avoiding it yeah
got hit pretty hard you know and I
someone family is doing and so you know
I've been talking with parents a lot
they're they're they're accomplished and
you know making sure she's healthy and
safe and you know so you know we aren't
taking it seriously obviously - thank
you a lot of people in this country a
lot of people are trying to try to stay
inside and beat it so we're taking
measures down here to do the same
uh you know hopefully this will this is
Paso or so how different are your draft
weekend plans because I mean so even
before I had this job draft weekend was
like the biggest party ever you know you
get all your boys together you're
watching the draft and I and I'm just a
fan I can't imagine what it would be
like when you're gonna hear your name
called and you've been waiting for that
moment since you're a little kid and now
because of because of like you said
because coronavirus like the draft is
not happening on TV like we've all grown
used to what how much of your draft plan
is different now than they used to be
you know we're still just because an
official but they're gonna do it and so
you know I'd love to have my family and
all my guys so so he generates two
bulldog teammates um I've already come
in but with this little virus going
around it's you're not supposed to have
more than ten people gathering I can get
my parents off like I'm Seattle because
because it's so bad over there so we're
kind of playing it by here I think you
want to stay down in California and try
to get my my family at least to be able
to be there with me because you
mentioned it's a huge moment something
I've been dreaming about for a long time
but you know to play by ear a day at a
time thing so you mentioned there you've
got Georgia teammates you got Washington
teammates how was it for you going from
I mean first of all like going to
Georgia you know as a recruit being the
number one quarterback in the country a
five-star recruit and then you're in
Athens Georgia which I don't know people
understand Athens Georgia is in the
middle of nowhere that had to be culture
shock for you take a leap
you know Georgia Georgia did an
outstanding job occurred to me with you
know the timeless mercury Mike bellow
was changed to it was shot on earth and
it was Curtis Martin and Jim Chaney
and I was a kid from Washington let's
play another name he told me about not
to let my know we're learning old school
based on where all of us you know he had
done it he said it was it was one of the
best experience with his life so you
know I wanted to do that and try some
you know I'm so glad that did all the
relationships I made down in the state
of Georgia in Athens and with coaches
and teammates classmates everyone down
there you know I just did that to that
area really well and I loved my time
there you know even even after that I
was able to come back to Washington and
establish new new teammates to
defragment coach's class my future to
everything so you know I really valued
the the relationships and friendships
you know lessons I learned in both the
spots I was able to go all right how
cool are you and Jake from with each
other cuz you know you get hurt Jake
comes in takes the job and then you
transfer to Washington and now y'all are
in the same draft class so how's that
relationship really you know how hatred
towards someone are bad blood Jake's an
outstanding person and a hell of a
football player and a very smart guy and
I think we both handled that situation
very well you know you understand
there's only one quarterback gonna feel
at a time that's that's the tough part
about the position you get a room two or
three great quarterbacks that's really
hard to pick one
you know Jake has a ton of great
qualities I tell I have the same you
know and qualities and you know a really
good quarterback and you know it's a
tough decision for Coach smart to make
and I think you know the team felt it
Jake bolts belted that getta today
decisions had to be made and later on I
had to make a decision which was which
was the best for Milan for so you know
there's no bad blood between me and Jake
I actually gotta spend some time with
him down in Indianapolis to catch up him
and Charlie corner it was also down
there some of them southern Georgia boys
would like Swift and those other guys so
you know it was good to see those guys
be with them and and you know it's all
you know that they it stays like that
you see all those guys that baby back to
high school with all the same camps and
get all those all those things and they
get to this you know the top-tier stage
the NFL Combine off be together and get
you know that's just a really cool
experience now I
think like I mean even after that then
Justin fields comes in and I can
remember last year before the draft
talking to like Isaac Nauta and some of
the other Georgia players and like every
Georgia player I talked to you would say
that you have the strongest arm of all
all the between just appeals Jake Jake
Fromm and yourself it was like Eason has
the best tools to play the quarterback
position as you now compare yourself to
Joe burrow and to uh
and Justin Herbert and Jordan love is
that something that like you even see
yourself like your arm strength is just
on a different tier than those guys yeah
I think everyone in this class has done
some outstanding things on the field in
their careers and they can play really
well at the next level now in terms of
Milan arms rank around football ability
oh yeah how like when you're a kid you
just understand that like playing Pop
Warner football like damn I got a pretty
strong arm a little bit strong and
everyone else there it's not something
kind of developed as you got older
develop mechanics throw the football on
the baseball and even pass the
basketball I used to leave the
basketball team an assistant as a
pitcher on the baseball field and also a
quarterback so and here's the one who
expand you know 30 minutes before the
bus got there before elementary school
working on my farm on the ball in the
shell finish in opposite populous which
I didn't understand any young age with
all those things meant but as I grew up
muscle memory him and my arm my arm
strength developed with my big for you
know octagon so a lot of us do that
girl's due to my dad for starting that
early the rest is just come and you'll
find him some things how fast could you
throw it was your fastball in baseball
well I baseball as my sophomore year 93
damn
so you see you're pretty good picture
which we're finding that a lot of
quarterbacks now like my Holmes is the
one everybody's gonna talk about but a
Tom Brady pretty good baseball player as
well so that's it's a nice background to
have haven't played baseball that well
my high school wasn't very big and I
wasn't like tiny either but you know all
the guys that played football season was
over you go in the basketball gym the
bachelors over here big enough that love
baseball two years or so another season
is an awesome place and you know I'm
standing baseball basketball football
program and you know the athletic part
of my life was was a fan of the law so
how was that year sitting out at u-dub
for you then like I mean you've been a
competitor your whole life and then you
go somewhere in you have to sit and
watch yeah so you know I got experience
you know a little bit of that true
sophomore at Georgia when I went down I
was out for number weeks and then you
know when I was able to play and
obviously Jake was playing a little to
tune the ball inside the experience that
he as a competitor and as a you know on
the inside bit stomp you know I you know
like my favorite thing to do but little
on Saturdays was taking away and I don't
want to be the guy I'll leave the troops
out of the tunnel and swing the ball
around me are you know ninety thousand
people because that's what I love to do
you know when that stripped away from
you it's hard as a competitor president
first my teammate it's no longer when I
did it to find the way to make the
narrative the problem team earlier
myself I didn't continue to be bad but
same guy well that's that same locker
room guy was and when I was at Georgia
was helping helping Jay from any way I
could and still complete the number twos
out of practice field when I was active
Washington I was able to learn a lot
from Jay privately he he handled this
business in the film room on the
practice field the weight room so you
know there's a lot of lessons to learn
there from from a competitive standpoint
it was really challenging but as a
leader that's the first console able to
grow and find new appreciation for
football you know Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday practices were my sadness so I
was able to go out there on
funny kinda loose on the leap day and
really on Saturdays as we go out there
and you know not be a cheerleader would
be a you know be a leader in style I
could actually play but and you know
take take things here and there and
learn from implementing and making
English last season now something that
that I have caught myself saying a lot
about you it's like 10 years ago you
would've been the number one quarterback
in this class you know you have
prototypical size we talked about your
arm strength which is crazy and you've
played in a pro style system like you've
been under center you've run play-action
you've had your back to the defense but
it feels like right now there's this
shift
everybody wants Lamar Jackson or you
know Patrick mahomes even you know Baker
Mayfield Russell Wilson guys who can
move around in the pocket a little bit
more how do you sell yourself to GM's
who are it feels like everybody's in a
copycat league whether they're all
looking for the next wave a quarterback
yeah today you know I'm not gonna outrun
you know a ton of people when the in an
open field but I'm very very confident
my ability to maneuver around the pocket
get a creative create a pound throw the
football you know that's what my
strength is like I can throw a football
anywhere on the field for many spots so
I feel you know I feel very confident
when I ability to move around and do
that you know what I'm feeling today
like a guy you know guys like Tom Brady
or Mohammed skull rivers know all those
guys are still in the league and you
know having great careers and you know
I'm a pass first guy and I believe I
believe it and it make plays when
necessary so nothing whatever team is
looking for a guy like me with my own
strengths I think I'll fit it really
well you just mentioned Tom Brady Aaron
Rodgers to Philip Rivers has it occurred
to you that you might be on the same
team as one of those guys or Ben
Roethlisberger now one thing that
definitely stands out watching you play
and then watching the other quarterback
in this class like Alabama has four
first rounders at wide receiver Joe
borough had Justin Jefferson and Jamar
chase and you guys sent some athletes at
University of Washington and at Georgia
as well when you were there
is that something that you've heard a
lot about like man the the supporting
cast that some of these other
quarterbacks had is almost an unfair
advantage I mean yeah different things
those things but you know I not a lot of
my teammates that bull that Jordan
Washington I had outstanding playmakers
some very very locker room guys and in
both of my teams you know guys you know
guys like to it and Joe had you know
outstanding teams and they have they
also made us play so I think you gotta
get credit where credit is due
you know both Joe and two of me
incredible plays up there up there after
universities and I had a lot of
playmakers with them as well and you
know you look at you look at the David
Washington those guys are like
outstanding plays as well you know
whether it's there and fuller or Brian
Saban a minute you know these guys are
my draft plus you know their outstanding
teammates and football players one of
the other things you hear a lot from
Scouts I'm sure you've heard it too from
the media is that there are questions
about like your maturity that you might
be a guy who likes to go have fun on you
know Friday nights or Sunday nights and
and that that kind of affects in some
way how serious they think you take the
game so and I I mean I'll be honest I've
heard that too I've heard I have one GM
telling me like yeah you would love him
like you would love to go have beers
with this guy but when it comes to the
football side of things I think there is
a little bit of a stigma out there yeah
you know bottom line is I was a kid from
Washington knew and Athens Georgia is
it's 17 18 year old kid and you know I
kind of learned through that process on
my feet kind of on the fly so you know I
did just about what every other college
student would do and college athlete you
know I enjoyed myself and had fun at the
same time I never they never gotten laid
at my football career
my academics out there dealing every
year obviously it's like grew up under
older I was able to dial that down and
mature and grow up and obviously now I
when I made the decision to dananddana
fell and looks like the drought you know
i supreme confidence and know i am on
and off the field and you know that
instilling trust these teams servant
meeting i'm doing and you know the
morning someone get with these coach
when you see things i think you know the
trust is only going up and it's
different when you're a five-star
recruit who's you know that's right on
campus because every time you go out or
every time you pop it to a house party
everyone knows you're there and it's
immediately on twitter so you've been
dealing with the spotlight of being the
big man on campus since you were 17 or
18 years old you know i think you know
everything happens for a reason and you
want to be living
they don't regret anything I did and you
know I'm gonna be where I'm at today I'm
very happy to answer his questions and
steam controlers how for knickers I'll
answer honestly and we can move on from
there ya know I I think we all
appreciate the honesty instead of that
not like that didn't happen just own it
upfront last question I got for you man
and again I appreciate your time if you
could have your pick next year where you
playing in the NFL next season
everybody's gonna say cobs happy to play
but every kid grows up dreaming of
playing the NF own you've pictured
yourself in that Jersey so where would
you like to be Sox fan so you know
obviously they have a really great thing
going on with Russel Wilson right
tremendous play maker but you know
dancer question would probably be
Seattle as a CI cuz that's why I'm from
but you know wherever I go as you
mentioned before I'll leave exciting you
know be a drink I'm true it also here
I need it to work so only happen to be
anywhere other 32 teams ready to work
all right man I appreciate it stay safe
out there and a good luck the next 22
days here are gonna be kind of wild as
we get ready for the draft absolutely
all right thanks Jacob